bonsoir cola merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france les autorités qui
avaient donc commencé avec ciné on
rappelle les adolescents de 12 à 17 ans
mais là elles ont décidé d'abaisser
encore un peu plus cet âge à cinq ans
deuxième pays donc après les états unis
pour quelles raisons
c'est bon de voir
mes qualités de vaccination contre le
virus y assembler et a décidé que les
avantages s'ils sont plus importants et
besoin que les risques 73 membres ont
voté en faveur de la vaccination 2
contres lors d'un vote à bulletins
secrets
à mener des études sur les cultes âge
de jeunes enfants et ces études ont
montré un taux d'efficacité de
97% il faut t gazon de savoir que les
enfants reçoivent un tiers de la dose
pour les adultes paula comment
réagissent les parents sur place parce
qu'on sait que c'est un débat qui est
pas toujours évident chez les adultes
mais peut-être encore davantage chez
chez les enfants est ce que ses parents
sont inquiets ce qu'ils ont suffisamment
de retours sur ce vaccin
[Applaudissements]
martelly bennett est le père de quatre
enfants
il a déclaré que son enfant le plus joli
serait d'accéder à inciter la population
à suivre son exemple
une d'experts du gouvernement sur ye le
coureur virus a déclaré que celui de 50
% des israéliens en général soutenez la
vaccination des enfants
cela est largement dû au fait qu après
la vaccination les enfants n'avaient
plus besoin de s'isoler l'inscrit besoin
de recevoir des textes anti génie qui
peuvent être particulièrement un basique
par les jeunes enfants
l'université de bar ilan à celle à 12 a
publié le résultat d'une chute
dans le cadre de laquelle ils ont
interrogé 894 parent d'enfants entre 5
et 11 ans 57% de ses parents interrogés
et sec en faveur de la vaccination des
enfants
se sont donc au sein de la communauté
israélienne ultra hot d'or s'il y a une
certaine réticence mais ce problème se
posait déjà pour la vaccination en
général donc cela je change pas
lorsqu'il s'agit des enfants
ultra-orthodoxes alors ou trois
évidemment leur éviter de tomber malade
et de contaminer les autres il ya aussi
en france on a connu la même chose la
base du non de fermeture de deux classes
il y a eu beaucoup justement de
fermetures de classes en israël
trois grandes familles de toutes les
écoles entre mars et septembre 2021 le
groupe i de l'année scolaire actuelle
de l'année scolaire le premier ministre
israélien ma valise l'exacte à prouver
mes tests sérologiques pour les niveaux
environ 200 m2 à 6e les places doivent
fermer et qu'un enfant aucun parent et
testé positif
le mois dernier de nouvelles conditions
ont été présentés pour deux classes pour
se dire vers ici
un des enfants et testé positif avec
tous ses camarades
doivent prendre un test pcr si le test
est négatif il compte revenir le
lendemain à l'école tout en maintenant
les distances je sais que mes distancie
qualité avec les enfants des autres
classes puis sept jours plus tard ils
reçoivent un styliste puis un test pcr
davantage de ce système est que des
enfants ne doivent pas s'isoler un peu
là une dernière question un peu plus
globale à pour pour terminer en
l'entente le voit il serait qui a été un
laboratoire pour le monde entier qui
prend des mesures quand même assez
significative assez importante
aujourd'hui quel est le recul est ce que
la situation sanitaire en israël est
satisfaisante et s'en sort mieux que le
reste du monde dans sa globalité
maintenant
il va juste en dessous de 6 milliards de
considérer ses actifs en israël istres
de la santé a déclaré que le faisait
avec surmonter sa crise va
peut-être millions de personnes ont reçu
le deuxième dose de vaccin à leur appel
cela représente deux tiers de la
population
les promos risque et le ministre de la
santé est l'un signé un accord selon
lequel il n'y aura pas de restriction
pour les larges rassemblements sont
millions de doses ont été administrées
16 millions de 12 il s'était administré
et l'on pourrait pas venir je suis un
thé de vaccination de 88 % à l'échelle
du pays
des raisons majeures du soutien pour la
vaccination en israël c'est que les
autres obtenir des passeports gère vos
passeports vaccinale en israël si je n'a
pas reçu trois doses de vaccins dont
gens qui ne savent pas recevoir les
outsiders de l'an dernier qui sont les
accents les plus populaires en israël se
tourner vers astrazeneca
merci beaucoup place ailleurs ajourné
une certaine internationale en direct de
tel aviv d'avoir été avec nous pour nous
exposer dans cette situation en israël
et la vaccination notamment des plus
petits